I have an autistic son named Gavin.
He's 16.
Video gaming for him has been very positive.
He loves Xbox and it has helped him with processing.
It's helped him with language.
It's helped him with numbers.
It's helped him in so many ways.
And he just got this game and he's navigating it pretty well.
He's pretty good.
He has taught himself French and Spanish...
...and there's a big difference between him just watching a TV show or a movie...
...and actually playing a game because his mind is engaged.
He's using problem-solving skills.
He's trying to figure out how to get past this wall.
There you go, you did it!
I think the moment that I discovered Gavin really took to video gaming...
...was when I could see how he could problem-solve without me.
I didn't realize just how smart or how deep his intellect was...
...until he started video gaming.
My name is Nori Fox and "kilaM0Mjaro" is my gamer tag.